younger women like older men facts and
older men like younger women and so but
what happens to the women
that are in that older bracket they get
bitter right because High checks they
get better yeah they need such eggs
because they see they see the younger
girls doing what they used to do and
then they demonize the older guys for
going for younger women when those are
the women going for all the guys when
they were younger correct because when
you because everyone remembers like you
know when you're at school or college or
whatever yeah those girls that were at
College the guys that would roll up in
the the car in the astross
they will always go for the older guys
they always would and then what would
they tell you guys my entertainment
immature women have always liked older
men but in winter when it flips now and
they start to hit their Peak and decline
that's when they start demonizing the
men oh you guys are weird why couldn't
finally go your own age right girl for
younger girls yeah you was that girl
like 10 years ago